when you're fighting a guy like well how
about John Jones's use of you grab his
wrist and he comes over the top of the
nell bow yeah I mean that is hand
trapping yeah sure I mean it really was
is what it is or when he leverages Shera
oh yes limb destruction oh yeah that's
old school construction yeah how and why
that hasn't been rabbit hauled a lot
more although you do start to see that
that moment where we're you know I get
to all four I get to four points and I'm
gonna stand up and you just kind of
decide okay that's alright we'll get
back to the fence in that process of
standing up a lot of guys throw a fight
finishing kick there or just at least
take that chance to smash your leg with
one like if there's free shots that
exist in these moments and John Jones is
a master of finding them
he really is yeah I hope they figure out
what the [ __ ] they're gonna do with him
soon I don't know where they're stand
now in terms of like his suspension or
what-have-you but here's my ultimate
goal my hope my dream is that Cormier
fights deep a for the heavyweight title
and somewhere around then they announce
when john jones suspension is up they
announced John Jones versus Brock Lesnar
I just I mean look at their body types
and look at what they are and where do
they come from I mean I love it but I
know you've sat down with John and and
stuff but what did you like what did he
feel like you do know what I mean like
what what Reid did you get from him did
you feel like he was saying the things
that he thought you wanted to hear or
did you feel he was being honest in
genuine definitely both he's being
honest and he's also had some things
that he planned out I like John a lot I
really love that guy
but I think he surrounds himself with a
bunch of knuckleheads I think he's he's
around too many people that are a bad
influence and they I think he's a wild
man and I think when he's a wild man
around other people that are sort of
indulging that stuff with him this is
the word that I get not just from what I
know but from the people that know him
very well is that he just around the
wrong people you know he's got bad
influences and I mean if you can
identify that then you must change it
yeah it's not it's not to take any
personal responsibility away from
him either because I'm sure he also
makes for a bad influence to them I mean
if the [ __ ] baddest man on the planet
can live like this I'll live like this -
[ __ ] it let's do more coke yeah you know
let's what's party harder let's drive
fast let's go drunk I don't know you
know I don't know what the answer is for
a guy like John you know I really don't
know I mean it's uh he's got to have
that come to Jesus moment or not you
know maybe he just keeps doing what he's
doing it keeps beating everybody's ass
and people keep forgiving him and
hopefully he doesn't wind up in jail but
you should for sure get a driver you
know for sure get someone to [ __ ]
drive him around that's a bad it's a
good bandage but it's not gonna be it's
not the problem-solver yeah the truth is
I think I mean we got to live the life
that we want like we get to choose the
things that we do like we have free -
certainly
yeah to a certain extent I know free
will is something that's been to see
you've discussed and it's it's a
fascinating concept but to some degree
you know we are authoring our own lives
you know and and if it isn't going the
way that you want it small tiny changes
can push it a different way yeah it's
matter of whether or not he's willing to
make those changes and you know right
now I'm sure he just wants to get his
license back you know but like when I
see him like having these battles back
and forth with Chuck Liddell online like
you gotta walk away from that
yeah like Chuck Liddell is an old
warrior who's clearly taking too many
shots like and you know this is you know
calling them an old man and saying all
this stuff and it's like just be the
better man in the situation you're at
you're at the top of the heap right now
at the top of your game you don't want
some young guy doing this to you 15
years from now talking to you that way I
mean this is these are the dark days